I have something just really important for
you today, but it also happens to be entertaining
and I think [inaudible]
most of you are going to enjoy this. There's
a company called Salesforce. We've used this
company off and on to manage our ad sales
process. It's a CRM, a customer relationship
management tool, and it doesn't even really
matter what that is, but their CEO is a guy
named Mark Benioff and he's a smart guy. He
has some really progressive ideas, at least
in the context of someone who runs a huge
corporation and happens to be a multibillionaire,
reportedly worth more than six point $4 billion.
About two thirds of that in Salesforce company
stock. He has a narrative about capitalism,
about the role of big business that is pretty
different from what a lot of other big corporate
CEOs have and he's been talking for a while
now about a new capitalism, a more social
capitalism, capitalism without going off the
rails, so to speak, a capitalism that accounts
for the wellbeing, not just of the shareholders
as is often the case, but also of stakeholders
which include all employees, customers, the
environment.
Capitalism for social change rather than capitalism
for preventing social change. And he was interviewed
on CNBC by the usual suspects, including this
guy named Jim Cramer, who's known in the investment
world and he turned their world visibly upside
down and they didn't know what to do with
him. So we're going to look at some clips.
This is a 12 minute interview in total, which
you can find online. I'm going to play a few
clips for you. And throughout this you might
notice there will be times where the camera
is a wide shot. And you'll notice Jim Cramer
just looking exasperated with Mark Benioff,
who's not going to be bullied by the sort
of vulture capitalist mentality into saying
anything other than what Mark Benioff believes.
And he happens to believe many of the right
things. And you'll see Jim Cramer going on
him about are we really going to break up
big tech, which Elizabeth Warren has been
suggesting. And Mark Benioff says, yeah, yeah
we should.
Last night I heard capitalism under attack
as I never heard it before. And it made me
think that if it's dead, there are two visions.
There's your vision, which is to resurrect
it and make business the greatest Pratt platform,
social change, and there's another vision
which is that the government has to step in
because the billionaires are screwed up so
badly. Tell us how to get that. Not that blow.
They're probably right actually, but we do.
We need a new capitalism. We need a capitalism
that's more fair, more equitable, more sustainable
capitalism, capitalism that
values not just all shareholders but also
all stake holders and if we can put those
things together, I think it can be a new capitalism
to be very exciting for everybody.
I I do worry Mark that in the, in the vacuum,
in the vacuum of what you're talking about,
what I heard last night about big tech having
to be broken up simply because it's got tremendous
power, not even at the power's being used
unwisely, but where are you when it comes
down to breaking up Facebook, waking up Amazon,
breaking up alphabet. Aren't these great American
companies that hire a lot of people?
Well, you know how I feel gym. Facebook is
the new cigarettes. It's addictive. Bad for
you, Jim. Thereafter, your kids set's not
fanned off, changed the political ads that
are going on. There's, you know, not a commitment
to trust and truth and now they're co-mingling
the data of all of their acquisitions. Facebook
probably should be broken up because they're
using these assets in a way to further manipulate
even more people. I think that there needs
to be change. It hasn't happened fast enough.
Absolutely correct. He's a huge beneficiary
of the system that we have, but he's saying
plain and simple that the system still has
to be changed and Kramer pushes back because
he just doesn't, I mean he doesn't like it.
He can't believe that a multibillionaire,
a huge corporate CEO is saying this stuff
and Mark Benioff here to the disbelief of
the people on the panel explaining that Salesforce
has returned great value to investors. Investors
in Salesforce have done really well financially,
but that they're also providing a return to
stakeholders and focusing on the environment
and more.
Mark, you've been talking for some time now
about, and that's the new capitalism gym,
which is that, look, we have to actually value
all stakeholders. We are. Look at all shit.
We'll share with the earlier [inaudible] are
important and we've had a great shareholder
return at Salesforce. I heard you earlier
mentioned at 3500% since I was first year
right there, right there in 2004 if you bought
our stock, well that's a 3500% return, but
I had a great stakeholder return too. During
that same period, we've given over $300 million
for grants, 4 million hours of volunteerism,
40,000 nonprofits and NGOs for free running
on our service, and we're a net zero company,
be fully renewable by 2025 that's our stakeholder
return. We issue a stakeholder report, so
we have a shareholder return and a shareholder
report. We have a stakeholder return, a stakeholder
report, and I think that's something the sec
can do by the way. They could put, you know
I mentioned that in my op ed.
What a concept, right? I mean blowing their
minds. You can see that these people, they're
looking at each other, they're smirking, they're
rolling their eyes. They can't believe that
a company that makes money also treats the
planet in a more responsible way and it treats
stakeholders as an important part of the considerations
that are made when you make business decisions.
Now, disclaimer, time. I'm not saying Mark
Benioff is perfect. I'm not saying Salesforce
is the perfect company and there are no negative
externalities to what Salesforce does there
well may be, but the way in which these simple
socially democratic ideas are coming from
a multibillionaire CEO and triggering Jim
Kramer is just delightful. Watch Kramer in
this next clip, if you're watching, if you're
just listening, I encourage you to find the
full interview online while David Faber takes
a turn asking some questions of Mark Benioff.
Jim Cramer looks perplexed as Mark Benioff
explains, Hey, there are actually CEOs all
over the world being more thoughtful about
how we run our businesses.
What are the metrics? How do you measure this
given it is growing in importance. We hear
about it all the time now from real money,
not just sort of a, you know, a broad sense
that there's interest in it, but people actually
who want to put dollars behind them. Well,
my peers certainly do. When I talked to the
largest CEOs in the world yesterday, I was
in Munich, Germany with one of the largest
company in Germany with their CEO. They have
a major program into place just as we do just
as many others do. I was in London on Monday.
I see the same thing throughout Europe. It's
probably happening faster there. The United
nations sustainable development goals are
the 17 core initiatives that are laid out
by the UN of how we're trying to improve the
state of the world and companies should have
to report how they're doing against those
goals that that just makes complete sense
to me.
If we're not all into improving the state
of the world, then what are we all into? Did
you believe the business round table when
they changed their statement or do you think
as some do that it was really more than just
kind of talked to get on the right side of
the politics of it? The business round table
has said now exactly the same thing. The purpose
of the corporation is to value stakeholders
as important as shareholders that the traditional
Milton Friedman concept that that it's only
about the shareholder, that the CEO's only
job is to maximize shareholder return is dead.
Wow. Oversight regulation working together.
Milton Friedman's teachings are obsolete.
It's not only about maximizing shareholder
value. Socialism, no, this is not socialism.
This is social democracy. It's social capitalism.
Mark Benioff doesn't say big corporations
shouldn't exist. Mark Benioff doesn't say
billionaires like him shouldn't exist. He
is saying that we can do capitalism in a different
way, still make money, but consider all stakeholders.
Consider the environment. This is CNBC. Mind
you, this is a billionaire tech CEO and you'll
see the wide shot again. Show Jim Kramer who
was just laughing to himself. He can't believe
this is happening on CNBC. He's here.
We need to value all stakeholders and all
shareholders. Now, when I say stakeholders,
what do I mean? I mean our employees, our
customers, our partners, you know, but I also
mean like I'm in from San Francisco. We have
a horrible homeless problem there. The homeless
are a stakeholder for me. That's why I was
fighting for proposition C, a tax on ourself
because we have to get to, we have to deal
with the homeless situation in San Francisco
as the largest employer in San Francisco.
I'm not focused on that if they aren't one
of my key stakeholders than what is,
that was the question I had because at tech
crunch you said if your orientation is just
about making money, you're not going to hang
out for very long. As a CEO or founder of
the company. My question was, if you don't,
then what you, your board fires you, your
sales drop, you know you can't hire anybody.
What is the consequence of running a foul
of that?
Well, you can see that in my industry, which
is for CEOs who do not take this approach,
they are really at risk and they can be extremely
vulnerable, especially during economic times
that become turbulent,
stunning, right? Who could have imagined?
You could be a corporate, a CEO or a big corporation
and care about other people. Then Benioff
brings up climate change, which is just like,
it's lost on these folks and you'll see them
all smirk at each other.
What am I doing wrong? I need to be thinking
about the public schools, the homeless. Oh,
and I also need to be thinking about not just
profit, but planet. I need to be thinking
about the planet. What are my emissions? You
know, that is part of the new world we're
in. That gets back to David's question on
what about the sustainable development goals
in the UN? That is the connectivity. That's
the map. We can lay it out. Then we can measure.
If we can measure it, we can have impact.
That's our one that we all know that we understand
how to do that. Jim, I know has to finish,
but there's some shareholders right now or
listening to you who probably like what are
you talking about? You seem to be abandoning
what I would want, which is just you focus
on improving the profitability of this company.
You worry that you freak some of these people
out and what do they say to you when they
hear that if they're not onboard with your
view, this is how to improve the profitability
of a company. This is how to make a great
company. This is how to have a company that
customers want to do business with, that attracts
employees, that develops partnerships, that
integrates local communities, that saves the
planet. This is about having a great company
and look at our company. Look at our financial
return since we went public right here in
2004 look at how we rank against everyone
else over the last same 15 year period. I'm
sure that you'll see we're in the very top
echelon and I'll tell you how we did it. We
valued stakeholders as much as shareholders.
Consider that you improve the company by caring
about the world in which the company exists.
By caring about the people who could be employees
or potential employees, customers of the company,
just people who exist on this planet. Shocking,
right? And half of what makes this great is
the content of what Mark Benioff is saying.
The other half is just how triggered Jim Cramer
is and his incredulous reactions to what is
being said. Really great stuff. And you know,
I mean, listen, I, as I say, don't idolize
politicians, don't idolize big corporate CEOs.
He's still the CEO of a huge corporation that
I'm sure does things that we would all disagree
with. But this was just a delightful wake
up call and taking it right to the horse's
mouth. Check out the full interview online.
It's only about 12 or 13 minutes. Let me know
what you think about it.